today's guest video is from Grady at
practical engineering he's talking about
a tragedy and the lessons we learned and
the reasons why it happened are
fascinating also he made his own props
Grady take it away in the summer of 1981
the Hyatt Regency Hotel in Kansas City
Missouri hosted a large party in the
multi-story atrium area during the event
suspended walkways on the 2nd and 4th
floors collapsed killing over a hundred
people and injuring over 200 more at the
time the accident was the worst
structural failure in US history in the
wake of the disaster
investigators discovered a change to the
original design of the walkways that was
proposed by the fabricator and
mistakenly approved by the structural
engineer what at first glance seem like
a subtle adjustment to the design turned
out to be the root cause of the failure
- suspended walkways span the atrium in
the Hyatt Regency with the second floor
walkway directly below the 4th floor
walkway each was supported by a series
of box girders suspended by hanger rods
and retained by nuts and washers the
original design called for a single pair
of hanger rods which would pass through
each fourth floor girder to the second
floor girder below the fabricator
responsible for constructing the
walkways objected to this plan because
it would require screw threads for the
entire length of the hanger rods which
could easily be damaged during
construction so they proposed to split
the hanger rods into two sets one to
connect the fourth floor walkway to the
roof and one to connect the second floor
walkway up to the fourth floor girders
if you don't notice the significance of
this change you're not alone it was
approved by the engineer without a
detailed review or calculations which
would have revealed its inherent flaw in
this setup which represents the original
design the load of the two walkways is
independently transferred to the hanger
rods notice how I can lift each girder
without affecting the other now let's
look at the design change in this
configuration notice that the entire
weight of the second floor walkway is
being born
directly by the hanger rod but instead
by the girder above if I lift the fourth
floor walkway the second floor walkway
is lifted as well the hanger rods are
still carrying the same load at the top
but the two nuts on the upper girder are
supporting the weight of both walkways
this simple change effectively doubled
the load on those bolted connections
imagine that you and a friend are both
hanging on a rope the original design is
the equivalent of you both holding on to
the rope independently whereas the
design change is the equivalent of your
friend hanging on to your ankles
the total weight supported by the rope
is the same in both cases but your
likelihood of maintaining a grip is not
this subtle change was identified by
investigators as the primary cause of
failure with so many people on the
walkways that evening the load on the
connections was too great the box girder
split open slipping past the washers and
nuts leading to the collapse of both
walkways there is an implicit handshake
between a society and its engineers we
hardly have a choice but to trust that
the constructed environment we live in
is safe and sound when an engineer seals
a design he or she takes responsibility
for its accuracy and safety to the
general public but to err is human and
that includes engineers so we try to
develop conventions and processes that
can catch and correct for mistakes
before they get too far and that
includes studying and learning from
errors made in the past the failure of
the Hyatt Regency walkways is an
important case study talk to nearly
every engineer with the goal that such a
tragedy will never occur again practical
engineering is filled with great videos
so go subscribe I would recommend
starting with Grady's video on
hydrostatics
next time a guest video with a prop that
has been to the moon
you